here are five ways to make money online
it's 2023 and you should be able to make
at least $10,000 a month from anywhere
in the world I'm going to tell you how
so keep watching number one you can
easily start a video editing service
people like myself entrepreneurs
businesses we need people to cut up this
type of content so if you have five
clients paying you $2,000 a month that's
your first 10K number two copywriting
entrepreneurs and businesses are sending
out thousands of emails and messages a
day we need people like you to write our
emails to write emotive language and so
again you have five clients paying you
$2,000 a month that's 10K for you the
third one is affiliate marketing is so
underrated right now I know people
making between $10 to $15,000 a month if
you don't want to show your face and you
don't have your own content you could
start monetizing other people's content
and then of course taking a commission
off the affiliate link number four
Consulting if you become an expert in
something and you grow an extremely
Niche audience you can actually bring in
a lot of new clients and start teaching
them exactly what you do